6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish. I'm Neil.
And I'm Beth. Do you remember your first day at school, Neil?
Yes, I do. I changed schools quite a lot when I was a kid, so I had lots of first days,
and they were never easy. How about you, Beth?
Well, my mum always tells this story about how I was crying a lot on my first day,
but apparently as soon as she left, I was quite happy, so my mum spent the day being a bit sad
and I was completely fine. Well, yes, starting school and making new friends is difficult for many
children, but it's not just the kids who find it challenging. For mums and dads who drop their
kids off at the school gates in the morning and pick them up again at the end of the school day,
making friends with other mums can be just as hard. Here, BBC presenter Nule Mugavan discusses
this problem using the term mum friends. So if you are a mum dropping off or picking up the kids
this week, how do you feel about hanging out with other mum friends? I find that term kind of
interesting as well, mum friends, they're never called friends, they're called mum friends.
Do you struggle to make those relationships or do you thrive on them or are you perfectly happy
without them? Mum friends are usually the mums of other children in your child's class at school.
They might go for coffee together, help out with babysitting or chat about being a mother,
but is making new mum friends really the positive experience it's often described as,
or an additional stress for already overworked mothers? That's what we'll be discussing in this
programme along with some useful new vocabulary. And if the idea of mum friends is new to you,
why not take a minute to read through the list of vocabulary before you listen? It's easy to
find on our website, BBCLearningEnglish.com. Now Beth, I have a question for you. Another term often
associated with mum friends is play date, a time that parents arrange for their children to play
together, but according to the Oxford English Dictionary, where does the term play date come from?
Is the origin in A Australia, B New Zealand or C the United States of America?
I'm going to guess the USA, C. Okay, feeling confident? Yes.
Well, we'll see at the end of the programme. For some mums, dropping their kids off at school reminds
them of when they themselves were little and under pressure to make friends. Listen as mum
Jane, chairing them cook, describes these feelings to BBC Radio 4 programme Woman's Hour.
The school gates take you back to being back at school. It's like you said, a high school clique.
It's you've got the sporty mums over there, you've got the glam mums over there, you've got, you know,
and if you don't fit into one of those, it's really, really difficult to navigate.
And yet you're all there just because your children were born in the same year.
It's a really weird thing.
Jane says that mums often form cliques, small groups of people who like spending time together
and seem unfriendly towards others. For example, at Jane's daughter's school, there's a clique
of sporty mums and a clique of glam mums who put on makeup and dress up. Jane uses the adjective
glam as a shortened form of the word glamour, meaning attractive and exciting.
Problems start when someone doesn't fit into one of the cliques. If you fit into a group of people,
you feel you belong and are accepted probably because you are similar to them.
So some mums feel rejected from cliques and worry about their children being left out of play dates.
But other mums don't mind if people want to be friends, that's fine. And if they don't,
that's fine too. Being a mum is hard enough without adding more stress.
Jane definitely belongs to this group, as she explains to BBC Radio 4's Woman's Hour.
I think I'd had some really bad experiences at baby groups, where you're trying to make your
child do yoga or paint when they're four months old and trying to bond with these other women.
And I just thought this is ridiculous. And I pretty much straightaway realised it was going
to be just down to luck if I met somebody that I clicked with.
Jane says it's down to luck if she makes mum friends. If you say something is down to luck,
you mean it depends on chance rather than any skill or effort you make. But there's always the
possibility you'll meet someone and click with them, become friends as soon as you start talking.
Well I know something that isn't down to luck Neil, the answer to your question.
Ah yes, I understood you about the origin of the term play date. Which country does it come from?
I think it's the USA. Well, Beth, you are right. So well done.
According to the Oxford English Dictionary, play date was first used in the Lincoln Daily Star
newspaper in Nebraska, USA, in 1915. Okay, let's recap the vocabulary we've learned
with play date, an arrangement that parents make for their young children to play together.
A clique is a small group of people who spend a lot of time together and may seem
unfriendly towards other people. Glam is short for glamorous, meaning a visually attractive
and exciting. If you fit into a group of people, you belong and feel accepted by them because
you're similar to them. If you say something is down to luck, you mean that it depends on chance
or luck rather than any skill or effort you make. And finally, if you click with someone,
you feel a friendly and positive connection when you meet them for the first time.
Once again, our time is up. Why not head over to the BBC Learning English website to find a quiz
and worksheet for this programme? Well, it's still fresh in your mind. See you again soon. Goodbye for now.
Bye.